you might think hey that's a phone and
you'd be halfway right it can make calls
but more importantly it's an internet
tablet which means you can very easily
get on online use this QWERTY keypad
right here to go to your favorite
websites but most importantly for a
Nokia it doesn't use the Symbian
operating system and if you've ever used
a Symbian operating system you know it's
hard to use and it's difficult to parse
and it's generally sort of a mess this
actually uses the my mo 5 OS which is a
Linux based and it's an 80% open-source
so if you're a hacker or a developer you
can easily get into it and develop some
apps so one of the cool things about the
n900 is that has this thing called a
panoramic desktop which means you can
kind of scroll through it and launch
multiple apps at the same time which
means like a multitask can go to
something like a music streaming website
like pipe machine and get on there start
streaming music and then without closing
it down without interrupting your music
flow you can go to Twitter go to
Facebook update a status without closing
out of anything else the n900 actually
uses a Mozilla based internet browser
one of the few mobile devices is
actually do this suck that iPhone with
most smartphones that use multi-touch
you have to pinch to zoom in and out of
things with the n900 it's different you
don't use a pinch you use a circular
base motion clockwise zooms in counter
clockwise zooms out the Nokia n900 also
has a 5 megapixel 5 megapixel camera on
it with carl zeiss lens the pictures are
crisp and actually noise free they're
better than most camera phone pics
although this if you were remembering
what we were talking about this doesn't
not actually a camera phone the other
cool thing about the n900 is that is
unlocked you can throw any SIM card you
want in it if you have t-mobile if you
have 18
if you have Verizon oh not Verizon
because Verizon doesn't use SIM cards
any international device will actually
work with it too so $650 may sound like
a lot but it's actually it's not
considering how much power the enitre
impacts into it it's not you shouldn't
think of it on your phone it's basically
a portable desktop device is it worth it
for what it gives you and for the added
bonus of being able to make calls with
it via Skype or few SIM card is a
fantastic fun